pure evil that was on display yesterday
morning inside the First Baptist Church
in Sutherland Springs Texas when a
gunman opened fire and killed 26 and
wounded 20 during Sunday service the
victims they ranged from 18 months old
to 77 years old and included the
pastor's 14 year old daughter the killer
26 year-old Devin Patrick Kelly don't he
want to use his name began shooting with
an ar-15 style rifle around 11:30 a.m.
30 minutes after the service began Kelly
then entered the sanctuary and gunned
down his victims many at point-blank
range
authorities collected hundreds of shell
casings from the church and 15 empty
magazines that held 30 rounds each
joining us now to shed light on this
horrific story from Sutherland Springs
Mike Jordan whose son witnessed the
attack and his close friends with the
man who confronted this killer and
likely prevented more carnage and from
Houston Texas Attorney General Ken
Paxton Mike let's talk to you first
your son who came face-to-face with the
killer is so distraught I mean he was
originally scheduled to join us tonight
and I don't blame him a 1-bit for being
too distraught and too frankly just
don't want to deal with this anymore
so thank you sir for joining us please
tell us how he is coping and what he has
told you about what he came face-to-face
with well he's coping with it it's it's
difficult a lot of his friends people
that he's known all of his life you know
died in this tragedy yesterday and we've
been interviewed you know one interview
after another and he's just to the point
after going to the vigil that was you
know here in Solan Springs earlier he's
at the breaking point I mean he narrowly
dodged three bullets that went through
his house and my grandson his son was in
the house like four feet away from one
of the bullets that came through their
wall you know so he's he's out of it
yeah he's coping with it but he'll be
okay but it's gonna take some time did
he go into the church at all himself
he did after after the shooter had been
after Shudra actually was engaged by
another person and left the scene my son
has some medical training he did go into
the church to try to help do what he
could you know to help the wounded you
know anybody he could help and I know I
saw him in one interview where he he
said I can't even verbalize what I saw
that's how bad and grisly it was and the
victim is very young - very old no yeah
yeah we you know we had children that
were killed
we had elder that were killed one person
that was a very good friend of my
daughter's actually her entire family
was killed in this incident so eight
people and one point yes exactly yeah
and you know to walk in and see that and
to know after the effect that he saw
that you know find out later that these
people were people he knew you know
people at him and and my daughter knew
grew up with it's it's really hard to
deal with
it really is let's go to bring in the
Attorney General of Texas Ken Paxton Ken
again Texas has been through a lot with
natural disasters of course the
hurricane the flooding and now this how
is the community they're coping and now
what potential policy changes or
anything can you do on a governmental
level given the mental health of this
individual and what we now know that the
Air Force did not do after he was
subjected to court-martial his name was
not entered into a background check
registry as it should have been what are
the authorities in Texas saying tonight
well first of all Texans are very
resilient they're just an amazing group
people you saw how they handled the
hurricane and the flooding that occurred
over a week-long period of time and how
well I think Texans both organized and
also just came to the rescue both in the
original aftermath and then just through
the weeks this is
to be no different we'll stand behind
these people you'll see lots of support
from the state you'll see lots of
support from charities from individuals
and I think that ultimately you know
we'll be here for those people for a
long time as far as what we can do I
mean we have laws on the book right now
that basically stop people in a
technical sense from caring at a church
now I think for small churches you're
gonna have to we're gonna have to change
the law to make it more clear that you
can carry in a church so that this gives
first responders time to show up
especially in a rural community where it
might take you know 10 15 20 minutes to
get to a site so I think we're gonna
have to rethink this and have churches
and businesses and schools think about
how they're gonna deal with this in the
future okay so can you cannot is against
the law in Texas to bring a gun into a
church is that what you're saying so the
so the way it works now is that you
cannot bring a concealed weapon into a
church however the church has to provide
you notice so if you're just reading a
statute you would see yourself as maybe
not being able to do it but the truth is
you can do it unless you're given notice
I think we need to make that more clear
because it's likely that people don't
carry because of the way they read the
statute and Michael from what you've
been able to discern was anyone in that
church anyone who survived what was
anyone carrying I mean I would be
surprised in Texas that if there wasn't
an individual in that church who had
carried a firearm into the church the
law or no law whatever and that's a kind
of an odd law but I mean they were hit
from behind so they had no chance to
react even if they had a gun maybe they
had you know tactical weapons training
but it's pretty hard to react when
you're being shot at from behind well
you know one of the points here there
was a individual that my son knew
personally normally he carries but a
small town like this you know people
show up to church they disarm leave
their guns in the carpet you don't
expect something like this to happen and
this particular day his wife stayed home
she wasn't feeling good so he left his
firearm with her you know so you know
I'm gonna go ahead and go to church
today well he survived
fortunately he was grazed by one of the
bullets they survived
and as he put it what if this was the
day that he didn't leave that farm at
home what if he did take it with him
what if you did conceal while he was in
that church you know I mean yes you have
a psycho shooting from the outside in
but think about that if you have one
person on the inside that is armed to
return fire it may not have stopped
people from dying but it would have
stopped that many people from dying it
would have been a distraction it would
have got the guys attention that hey
somebody's shooting at me what do I do
now well Mike what the the left the
American left is saying many and the
left are saying is that Republicans have
blood on their hands because they're
bought and paid for by the NRA that's
what they're saying tonight really well
that's amazing because the NRA has lots
of great programs for children they
teach you know firearm training the NRA
Republicans no one's responsible for
this and the left keeps putting blame
let me put it this way today a very good
friend of mine engaged today excuse me
yesterday a very good friend of mine
engaged the shooter with his ar-15 he
ran from his home to the shooting site
less than a block from a house here he
engaged the shooter with his ar-15 and
he shot the guy he we know for a fact he
shot him at least two to three times it
got stopped the guy it stopped him from
that point the shooter then ran got in
his vehicle
my friend shot him again they pursued
then later down the road after chased
the guy crashed and that was the end of
it but we think think about it this way
yes we lost 20 right now account is 26
people that we lost yesterday in this
tragedy but there was many more people
in that church that if he had not
engaged that shooter with his owner if
yeah it's if the Liberals if the
Liberals have their way and we're not
able to protect ourselves and he was not
able to do what he did think about how
many more people would have died and my
son who lived across the street think
about what would have happened there
what
that guy had pursued him his wife and my
grandson the tragedy a petition twice is
bad it's my can-can
thank you so much for joining us both of
you